yes
so we are live on youtube
do
oh danielle when you are when you can
travel again
where are you going
home
nice tell have you been you haven't been
to france
or did you go in summer yes i went one
week in summer last summer
um since then stay in berlin
yeah but your but your son
and your partner stayed in berlin or did
you all go
um to france no no we went all together
oh okay yeah that was the
goal show him to everyone yeah
present everyone wanted to see him
classic
and you danielle where are you going
when you come
good question maybe visited my sister in
munich
like she just got a baby last week so
that would be nice to go to but have to
wait
yeah how about you
i think i'll go to brazil when i can
that's the plan
i was a plan for this winter
but i think we have to push it for one
year
[Music]
i'll go to salvatore
i think it's been a it's amazing city
it's like 25 degrees 30
it's like big city near from the on the
coast
and like the water is like 25 sunny
you can drink coconut water yeah
should go
alright did you put the link in
[Music]
okay i will put it
in the chat also
so
ah alex is also here alex
yes i also sneaked in wow
that's great no it's looking where's
alex here am i
hey great to see you all
yeah good to see you yeah
so are the events in pi data suggest
happening uh online or
no we just discussed yesterday
i mean most of our people we know spent
in video conferences all day so we
thought
man let's not add another one in the
evening but
so we decided to uh as soon as we can do
it run an in-person event again we will
like really make everything happen in
like two three weeks time maybe
maybe look for something in early summer
and uh
have something outside something like
that so we say we said hey let's this is
super agile because
when we had the meeting in october which
was in person
just before we had the shutdowns again
everybody was like so happy they could
see each other in person again
and yeah
interesting yeah yeah also pi datalin is
holding up the online stream so
why bother
[Laughter]
let's see
we got 27 people cool
but i think a lot of meetups won't go
offline like i think
how people like these online meetups
yeah like yeah i think as long as you
don't have to show up your face and you
know like don't have to talk
i mean you just stay on mute and yeah
i don't know yeah it depends i guess
yeah but then it's very very passive
experience
yeah exactly yeah it's like conversating
yeah it's true
but you can attend a lot of different
meetups like some in u.s or
in i don't know like
yeah i think i still have like 300 pi
data videos still to
catch on i catch up to from like past
three years so
yeah but there's so many actually yeah
the
online content has really gone up i
guess there's so much of stuff
yeah pass on emory looking forward to
the
real like on in-person meetup when we
can
i think it's much more fun
yeah we need to find a host first and we
have pizza and beer
exactly that's actually like yeah
it's been yeah
did we start online meetups last year
by this no not by this time i guess from
march right
well march so yeah almost a year so
who are getting mastered soon
yeah i think
yeah i hope they also don't put up like
the what subway
that you will share your data with every
other
services thing yeah
i mean i'm pretty sure there are
anywhere sharing in some sense but yeah
i think victor can tell us more about it
i just got invited today and i just
thought my first thought
yeah thanks for sharing my phone number
because i don't care about this service
i mean we were just making fun about it
so i mean i think we have to start
like having having like extra devices
for this thing because that's like slack
just telegram
it's like like
oh that's too many
okay great i propose to start
yeah we have 30 yeah we have 30 people
and the people can just catch up when
they arrive
um so welcome to pi data
berlin so it's the first of the year
2021.
so happy new years everyone happy to see
you
on online hope to
be able to see one of you this year
and we'll see when but we don't thought
that you
will go to the talks but before i just
want to remind you about the
nam focus code of conduct um
so we'll do a short version of it so
a pi data is supported by non-focus
and so as part of them focus we have to
add up to the
call of conduct um we put the link in
the description but the short version is
be nice
uh don't try to be offensive to other
people
this is a place to connect but be
respectful of the others
and everything will be fine and now we
can start
with the first talk by viktor zimmermann
about the best practices in ethical data
collection
so victor cinnamon is a livestream based
computational linguist and postgraduate
working as a day hour
and working as a data scientist uh for
koenigsegg
and you can start whatever you want
victor
okay i'll just move a few things around
and then the half black screen is
intended
sorry um okay yeah we don't see
we just we see something weird we see
something different from the last time
that should not be the case oh okay
now it's ah okay that
does this work yes okay
okay uh yeah i'll be talking a bit about
best practices in
ethical data collection and
later on more generally about ethical
data science or data ethics yeah
um i think i don't have to further
introduce myself
i'm a computational linguist but i've
had increased interest in data ethics
and
bias in the past so here
is basically my repertoire
what i learned in the last few years
about data ethics and
what you can basically take away from
that and what you could
work with in this field
first off i am not the most qualified
person uh
on the subject like i'm an amateur in
everything i'll talk about here um but
not just
like academically i'm also obviously a
white man from a somewhat
privileged background so a lot of the
impacts i'll be talking about don't
really affect me i've
not experienced real discrimination
firsthand i
um let's see
oh there okay sorry there was a shot
like um
i come to this with a pretty moved point
of view
because um i can talk about ethics and
the theory of ethics and all that
as much as i want i won't really
have a glance at the impact all of these
policies all of these considerations
have on real people
so um please keep this in mind my view
is not
a singular uh point of reference for
this and it should not be
and um no matter how much we talk about
theory here keep in mind ethics is also
is always about uh application and
this especially in data science affects
millions of people every day
so that as a personal primer
also i'm not a philosopher and i
probably use every theory i mentioned
here completely wrong
if you show this to a real philosopher
so also
please don't be mean about
if i misrepresent your favorite theory
it was not my intention i
i like this framework i found and
i think it's kind of useful to
contextualize the topics i'll be talking
about but
don't read too much into it if you're
really deep into this
into the theoretical stuff behind it
okay
um also a bit about the content i'll be
talking about
there are few things which come into
mind
when you talk about data ethics which i
will
not touch on that much uh first of
machine ethics this is not about
self-driving cars or all of these
moral conundrums you usually see in
movies about
artificial intelligence it's not about
algorithmic bias necessarily
i will be talking about everything that
comes before this
so um how can we make decisions
that already minimize bias
before a machine gets the chance to
amplify
this starting from institutionalized
change to data collection
yeah um it's not about algorithmic
regulation i will not
be giving an any um advice to
governments here what they
should and should not outlaw
and uh i will not talk about [ __ ]
um so i will not be talking about fake
news i will not
talk about misrepresentation of data i
will not talk
about visualizations i think there's
there are no pictures in this
presentation
so um all of the things i'll be talking
about
have this good faith
background so everything can be taken in
good faith
we assume that there are just
well-intentioned actors
here trying to be better
let's start with the base basics so
ethics
that's a loaded word right um it's
if you want to be technical is the
theory of moral behavior so how
can we um define how one should act
how are you a good person basically
um it's a discursive field so
the most uh the best
thing you could get out of this is a
rule book
that tells you if i do this then there
uh
there will be ethical behavior as a
consequence and this
i cannot give you i cannot say uh do
this and this and then
your work will be ethical this is a
discussion
as much as it is a science so um
i can talk about frameworks here but i
cannot tell you
what and what isn't a ethical decision
um
this is a quote from one of the books
i used a lot in researching this
um ethics invites us to think about what
kind of people we want to be
but we also have to learn how to live
with the consequences of deciding wrong
so it's not only about
um what how do we derive
good decisions but also what do we do if
we get it wrong
and i think that's especially if you
look at all the controversies in data
science and machine learning
i think that's you almost even more
important
almost than getting it right the first
time
i will be talking about three
perspectives in this talk those are the
teleological ethics
uh the deontological
ethics and virtue ethics i'll explain
each of these
in a minute but those are basically the
three big
fields in ethics that most
theories fall into first
i will be firstly i will talk about
teleological ethics
this is your utilitarianism your
consequentialism
so it's about objectives and purposes
it's about impact assessment costs and
benefits you basically calculate
if something is ethical by weighing
costs and benefits against each other
then i'll be looking at
documentation data sheets impact
statements so the most bureaucratic
ethical
theory also gets the most bureaucratic
[Music]
tools to use to derive ethical
actions then we'll be looking at the
ontological ethics
this is about duties and rights
intrinsic moral values so
how can we make institutions that
enforce
good behavior we'll be talking about red
lines
things we will not cross no matter the
costs and benefits
basically we'll be talking about
regulation to some extent as i said not
really laws but internal regulations and
codes yeah and ethics codes as a
formalism for those and
lastly we'll be talking about virtue
ethics this is i think the most exciting
part this is about striving for a good
happy life
so um we don't only want to be
acting good but there there should be
some more motivation behind it right we
want to uh grow as a field as a
professional
we want to become better and not just
act better
right and this is basically looking at
that um
i'll present the theory of embedded
ethics which i think is very promising
here but also
open source aspirations who do we want
to be
as data scientists all of this falls
into
this field of ethics okay
um let's start with the geological
argument or consequentialists i'll use
these interchangeably and
philosophers will hack me for this first
of all
the primer why we talk about all this
all data is biased right
so that that is the fundamental law
of data science i think because if data
is not biased
you don't get information out of it
every data set is biased towards the
data it contains a white pages bias
towards whiteness a single data point is
biased towards that one point
and machine learning is really good in
finding that bias it's
oftentimes way better at finding bias
than human actors
so historical and inherent biases are
still represented by proxy and
unproblematic data sets
for example newspapers come up a lot you
think
newspapers are really unproblematic they
are boring they are
um pretty um
they are not burdened by politics so to
speak but they are mostly written by
white men historically so there are a
lot of
biases that come into this through back
channels by proxies and
as we as we said machine learning
algorithms are really good
at finding these biases despite they
them not being intentionally there
um the idea is that documentation and
transparency of collection methods
can help mitigate unfair outcomes down
the line
so if we are aware of these biases and
if we document these bi
biases we can apply algorithms and we
can
modify our algorithms down the line
better
and tailor them to the biases we have
and
work towards mitigate and that's the
idea i want to convey here
so we'll be looking at data sheets
those are deliberate documentation of
data of the
data collection process it's basically a
parallel
to spec sheets for electronic components
so every electronic component comes with
a sheet with all the information
the manufacturer has about that
component and
data sheets basically aim to provide the
same information
for data sets an exhaustive list of
parameters and circumstances on which
this data was
collected um the general idea
comes from timnit gibru for general
machine learning data sets but there's
also
um one more specific for natural
language processing
by ah what's her name um
i think bender is the last name i'm liam
bender right
for natural language processing
and the idea is that these questions
should be answered before during and
after data collection
so this is very much part of the process
process these questions basically
guide you through the collection process
and
highlight some issues that could arise
during data
collection before they appear so
um let's look at a few examples the
whole survey is
pretty long but exhaustive
so for motivation what purpose was the
data set created and who funded the
creation of the data set
this is really important if someone else
uses the data set and wants to
understand what code kind of biases
could be in the data set
right funding is one motivational
feature that could inform your decision
how this data arrived at the point where
we find it
composition is obviously very important
so are there any errors sources of noise
what are recommended data splits
so if the data is
not chronological then a date
recommended data split would be to use
each fifth
or third data point that would be more
reasonable than
slicing them by thirds this way because
then you would have
individual time frames which are not
similar
um yeah so what is the makeup
of this and also like uh data protection
issues is it possible to
identify individuals would come up here
um then there's the collection process
who was involved
does the data relate to people again and
did the people in question consent
to having their data collected
oftentimes if you use
twitter you don't contact every twitter
user so there are degrees of consent of
course they consent to
having their data out there but they did
not consent to this specific use so
anyone down the line could have other
objections to using the data than you
had while collecting
it and giving this information allows
the person down the line to make their
own ethical judgment
completely independent of your own
judgment when creating the data set
and preprocessing can introduce
bias you can provide the raw data set to
compare
which is helpful information to
users are also quite important so you
know your data set best so you can
probably predict best
if there are any tasks you don't want
your data set used
at so if you have widely
misrepresentative
[Music]
sociological data you might want to
outline some
so geological uh fields where this would
produce very bad results because some
some groups of people are just not
represented in your data set and you
can't draw
conclusions on the whole population like
lots of data sets
come out of university and come out of
university students which are not
representative of the whole population
this would be a point where you
would mention that then distribution
um how will this be disre distributed
do third parties have access to the data
and who
maintains the data if you want to add to
the data is their mechanism to do so
so a lot of questions but
um the idea is that you have a
standardized documentation for data sets
which ideally is comparable between
data sets and it asks the right
questions at the right time
so you might not even think about tests
and training splits when creating a data
set because you're not
a machine learning person are you you
just
create data that can be used by a
different team down the line
and by providing this data by being
aware that this is a relevant
information to give you at least
put some thought into ethical or
at least um not necessarily ethical but
just useful concerns
that could be uh useful later down the
line
it prevents miscommunication because of
this
you know the data better as i said
before so
you can make sure that that knowledge is
not lost
and by providing as much information as
possible you
allow users to make their own value
judgment as i said before
instead of putting out files until their
standards are met
so um you don't you can anticipate some
um fires before they happen just because
you know the data better than anyone
else and someone else does not have to
react to a [ __ ] storm because their data
did something stupid
or their system did something stupid so
you can prevent fires before they happen
something similar are impact statements
so most major machine learning
conferences for example
neurips started to ask researchers to
provide impact
statements with their papers um those
are similar to
data sheets just way more unstructured
so but still consult them whenever
available for your
data collection just general tools
because some algorithms perturb data in
ways
that are unintentional if used for
different purposes
so you might transform your data during
pre-processing
for one task for one intended task but
if you
then decide to use that per update for
some other tasks
there could be unintended consequential
consequences and this
would ideally be found in uh
in an impact statement that would be
kind of more complicated you have to
had to spend more time looking into the
paper
if you would have to find that out
yourself
then okay so so much about data sheet
and impact statements let's move on to
deontological data science
ethical data science from data sheets
works under the assumption that more
knowledge allows for better calculations
of moral costs and benefits
like you give more information to the
decider
about what they can and cannot do with
your data and how the data was
collected and this if this fits their
ethical
judgment but it does not answer the
following questions really well what
kind of red lines are there so are there
boundaries we don't want to crossover is
everything
allowed if we find enough benefits to
justify it
um how are they enforced are they
enforceable
like other mechanisms if some if
we cross one of these red lines and
how do we as a profession want to be
perceived by clients and by society
nobody thinks differently of any company
or any
project if they have data sheets or not
but that might be a consideration
worth having for your team when talking
about ethics
these questions also kind of guided the
rise in ethics codes in medicine
after the second world war i don't think
we have to go into detail why
ethics codes became kind of important
after the second world war but a lot of
bad things happened during that time
that
made codifying the ethics of the
medicine discipline really important
and they should still guide researchers
working with fundamentally
human data even though we don't cut
people open
literally we still interact with people
and we still
impact people's life and that's why data
science
is still kind of similar to medicine in
some ways and i think
ethics is one of the major ways this is
true
so what would or what should an ethics
code for data scientists look
like here are a few
goals that outward facing goals that
uh an ethics code
should or at least should consider
um i won't go into each of them but if
you want to design an ethics code you
should
at least talk about each of them um i'll
highlight a few
like protect vulnerable populations who
could be harmed by the professions
activities
um here we could talk uh when talking
about data science we can talk about
data protection
um that it should be an ethical duty
towards your customer so
your project should be defined with
data protection standards in mind and
not be stripped down until they meet
the european guidelines or so
and can you test justify paying your
turka starvation wages
like can you is that a red line you
won't cross or is it okay that
mechanical turk workers just get two
euros in over
um those are things you could talk about
protecting vulnerable populations with
your ethics code
um you want to establish a profession as
a distinct moral community
so you not only want to promote
standards in your own organization but
probably um across your entire field
you want to promote ethics standard
conferences and in the wider profession
you want to support
programs that enhan further diversity
and self-reflection in the community
so you want to build a strong
moral code in the community not just
in paper you want to provide a basis for
public expectations and evaluation of
the profession so
nobody takes your ethics code seriously
if they don't
care if they can't evaluate it if
i can't see that you actually care and
that you actually
enforce these measures so publish and
promote
the ethics code use open data and open
source as a default so
try to push as much as you can
to open source and open data and justify
if you can't
so you can basically show show your
cards that you're
not that you are playing fairly
and respond to past hands done by the
profession so
take a pic if it's cambridge analytica
or any other
major scandal minor scandal there there
are
a lot of scandals in machine learning
and data science
that have to be addressed and that you
can learn from
so keep up to date right try to hire the
staff acknowledge the size of the task
all of this can be put into an ethics
code
um to prevent at least the major
hurdles that we have already seen
there are also some inward facing goals
this is mostly
about harassment so keep the morale up
in your own team
try to work towards a common goal
those are not really data science
specific so i skipped most of them
one of the important things is this
ethics code should be under continual
review
so this is not set in stone and then
done forever um
and you should establish a process in uh
in which
your code will be your ethics code will
be reviewed and that should not be
human resources a lot of time these
um like harassment is obviously one of
the
things where you go to human resources
but you should not
delegate all moral responsibility in
your company to human resources
um secondly uh dtr detail under
unethical behavior by identifying
sanctions and by creating an
environment in which reporting unethical
behavior
is affirmed so are there consequences of
some someone acts unethical
can someone report these uh this
unethical behavior without risking their
job
and assumption sanctions actually
enforce
and should they be enforced because like
journalism has a pretty strong moral
code but they
have basically no enforcement so you can
talk
about each of these points and argue
again so for it but you should at least
consider them
that's basically what i want to
highlight here
um no matter what project what team what
company you should have some
ethics code that defines your values and
red lines um
not necessarily so you have the document
but
so you have talked about the values you
hold as a team
and about the values you hold about your
field
and you agree on these values to some
extent
as a team and i think both of these
things are important to talk about
before tackling any project
so you know you are on the same page on
these ethical
issues um this code does not need to
meet every point in that list especially
if you
are like three people you don't need a
full fleshed out ethics code you just
have
should have that conversation and um
an ethics code should be a mission
statement first regulation second
so the goal is to make ethical decision
making a central part of the process
and not just another compliance step if
it's just
another box you have to take when
tackling a project then
your ethics code failed it should be
understood that this is a somewhat
central
part of any project okay
um we talked about data sheets we talked
about
ethics code now move to become
better people first of all i have a
question
what is a good doctor like the mental
image you have
of a good doctor what traits a good
doctor has
um i think you all have something in
mind i i think it's pretty
similar similar for each of you
what is a good data scientist it's the
next question
and i think there will not be one
singular answer
like for a doctor he's patient he's
honest with his patients
but what makes a good data scientist
there are no
real stereotypes about data scientists
and
about good data scientists even less
there are few role models about data
scientists
so a good doctor is not good because the
profession
and the daily procedures for them to be
like a
good doctor is not good because he has
an ethics code or because
he follows a specific checklist he's
good because of his virtues
so how do we move from
these better processes and structures
which are
really important and we should have but
how do you move from them
to become actually better professionals
how do we become good data scientists
instead of
data scientists that act to act to
certain principles
and what does a better professional look
like if there are no clear accepted role
models
if we don't have that mental image of a
good data scientist what can we orient
ourselves
to um
first there are
about five principles for aai in society
those are hotly debated but i
um copied them from a paper so i think
at least some peer review would agree
with them
beneficials non-malfeasance so don't
don't do evil autonomy justice
and explicability last one is like
explainability but also
that you are under review that you can
explain yourself
and your actions um those are closely
aligned to biomedical ethics
so um those are in somewhat a contrast
to
tech and information ethics and i went
into that
before that we are surprisingly similar
to
medicine when it comes to ethics in our
field
but still the gap between principles and
practice
is large like we all would agree that um
these five principles and so much more
like kindness or
patience are good qualities to have but
do we actually
act according to them in our daily
data science practice um and
i think the big problem here is we all
enjoyed some kind of ethical education
as data scientists by
reading the news we saw all of these
huge scandals we saw cambridge analytica
if you're into
an lp you saw a lot of bias in search
engines and embeddings
and you've read all the papers and
you've read the blog posts about them
but we that's all basically we get our
ethics education from
case studies that highlight the most
extreme
cases and they highlight the negative
cases so we don't get
any insights into how to be a good an
ethical data scientist on a
day-to-day basis we only get the worst
cases which are not applicable to our
daily lives at all
like we all agree that we don't want to
bias in our search engines and we
look at cambridge analytica and think
that could never happen to us because we
are good people
so there's a kind of disconnect between
our education and
actually the requirements we have
for our job when we want to act
ethically
so here is the idea from
virtue ethics treat data ethics as any
other data science skill like coding
like statistics like
logical reasoning or any other muscle
you have
like learning a language like learning
play guitar
you can train your ethics basically
it grows through training that's the
fundamental idea of virtual ethics that
you can train
through practicing virtue you could can
become more virtuous
so here's the takeaway basically make a
conscious and concrete effort to engage
in virtuous behavior i'll show examples
in a minute
and practice data ethics on a day-to-day
basis like you would
train your language making your duolingo
hitting your duolingo goal every single
day you should practice
data ethics on a day-to-day basis to
become a better
data scientist um
let's look at the example of developing
code there are lots of questions you can
ask yourself while
writing code so am i reusing others code
responsibly
that this deliberation fosters some
reflection on citizenship
responsibilities generosity
you can ask am i providing the necessary
credit for the work of others
that fosters gratitude and humility am i
going to share my code with others
you are talking about community and
thinking about future users
and could my code be misused and
suddenly
you're making decisions about
societal responsibilities
then you can also link your own
experiences to these big picture
ethical conundrums we saw before like we
want to train
the little stuff we can still link to
the big the big scandals the big
ethical questions we have like
one thing that comes up with developing
code is individual
cons institutional and community
ownership right
so who should own the code who owns the
code
and then you're talking about open
science open software national
international copyright and patent
is an iq so how does one manage
conflicting priorities
and you're talking about limits of
ownership of digital artifacts
your uh might consider coding community
norms and requirements
so how does one manage conflicting
priorities to self and communities
again open source um social norms and
requirements are also
a topic when talking about developing
code so
how does any code contribute to the
broader body of the digital landscape
and suddenly we're talking about
fabrication falsification
plagiarism in research
so from the thing you do every day you
can make
conscious considerations about how this
affects others how this affects your
field at large and practicing this
consciously
um ideally leads to you becoming a more
ethical
data scientist so
to wrap this whole thing up conscious
documentation and ethics could help to
hold institutions accountable and false
ethical considerations they are
basically a safety net
for ethics and i think institutions
especially large ones
need the safety net because there are so
many factors that drive those
institutions towards
unethical behavior
but and turner internalizing and
practicing the underlying virtues is
much harder
actually becoming better is harder than
just following rules
just like learning a language and
playing the guitar make every day the
conscious effort to become a better data
scientist by reflecting on your work
and making the effort so
making the effort actually means
engaging in open data
reading up on the issues that come up in
ethical data science
and for finding moral examples so
role models you can aspire to by
engaging in this community
so try to find someone you want to be
basically and try to emulate them
try to become a better person by example
which is hard because there are not that
many examples in our field
at least not conscious ones you can't
find them
thank you i think that's all from me
there we go
also um one thing i have some further
reading on the slides
um the algorithm watch is like a german
nonprofit that does uh really good work
there are a lot of papers here i think
tim nick gabriel and emily and bender
are great i think you know them from the
recent scandals um
surrounding uh timnit gebru
sulein blodgett does a lot of work on
bias she was the one
who introduced me to data ethics in
general
and yeah the other things i think papers
i
found really helpful when learning about
all of this
so all of this is on the slides which
you can find
at least on my website in the near
future
yeah so now i'm done
great thank you very much
we got some questions from the youtube
channel
so the first one is so is using biased
data still unethical if the bias is
recognized
and conclusion drawn from the data are
limited to the population from which the
data was drawn
um if you if
um i think that's fair yes
you would have to look at the example
for example
um if this all leads to a popular
science article somewhere on a website
then it still can get misconstrued but
if you
are very conscious about the biases and
make certain that everyone knows that
these biases exist and this is only a
statement about the sample comp
uh sample population from which these
samples are
drawn and make everyone aware of all the
biases you found in them and this is not
representative and all that yeah i think
that's fair
i think there are that's at least
better than most most
uh things we do in data science
has as a standard so yeah i think that's
perfectly fine but again
i'm not the authority of what is and
what isn't
ethical i presented a framework how to
assess or come to your own conclusions
and become better
through this framework not i don't want
to
like say what isn't isn't ethical
in this field because i'm not
like an expert in this field i'm very
much
a junior in data science so i i don't
have the answers and i don't want to
make
big uh judgments on ethics
that i don't stand by in like two months
makes sense um we got also a second one
from youtube um the problem i see
is that it is very impractical to act
at risky colleague sorry i don't know i
don't know too
artistically you know what i mean
how would we establish a trust if an
ethical behavior
can yield in an advantage
that's a big question right because we
don't have
any we have very little oversight
in that regard we have not we don't have
much governmental
regulation that forces us to be ethical
we only have
we only have each other basically so one
thing we can do
is um have some solidarity within the
profession
i think we are in a somewhat good place
with data science
that we can through societal pressure
and for some standards and uh demand
those standards but yeah um
we live under a system that does not
necessarily
value ethical actions over
advantageous actions and this is the big
that this is a big problem this is why i
don't want to get into
uh government regulation here because
this is a whole can of worms
and yeah
great thank you another question also
um speaking of ethics how can you
address
trustworthiness in the model you build
um could you repeat the last part uh
how come can we address trustworthiness
in the model you build what was the last
word i
didn't get the last one sorry build
building
and the models we built yes oh sorry
um documentation
yeah sorry um i think that documentation
and transparency helps
like if um with the
current um and now it's not a model but
with a corona app in germany it helped
that the whole code was online and that
a lot of
professionals looked at the code and
said that it was top-notch
so if we can have
some transparency in the models we build
and if a lot of people
can look at them and see how they are
used
then that builds trust of course if if
everything is closed and we
only talk about the model and don't show
it that's harder
and you have to move you have to move
mountains
for your institution to end that trust
in other ways through community
engagement and so on so you as an
institution can be trusted
to even behind closed doors work under
ethical guidelines
yeah but trust trust is a major issue
great
any other questions from the audience
otherwise i think we can
thank victor on my time for the great
speech
with a great presentation
okay um so i propose to have a
one two minutes break uh before we go to
the next
to the next to the next stock
um so yeah if you want to uh
grab some water or something like that
it's the time to go to do that
i personally need to drink something so
i will just disconnect for
10 minutes but feel free to chat
oh do we still have everyone
[Music]
i guess yeah i think
do we have some pre some people from
america so no
of south america
do we have people from asia
um yes yeah i'm from china
but right now i'm i'm living berlin so
yeah we're in the same zone okay
nice
do we have people from africa
nope
still missing australia that's it's a
small really small population so i do
not expect
anyone from australia no
okay so everyone is from europe i'll
prefer not to tell
okay so let's go
for the second patch
oh if someone wants more time
i will start now so
so we'll get the second talk by pranav
um so about gun so
the in and out action
so gann is uh
undergrad at bit app or vit
app university and is doing andros
research in deep learning system
especially
in era of nlp and computer vision
so welcome pranav and i will
you can share your screen here hopefully
i'm honorable
and can you see my screen now
yes yeah perfect so uh thanks everyone
for joining the
world in session it was a wonderful
session by mr victor so i'm pranav and
i'm an
undergrad from india i am i'm doing my
undergrad in computer science in vit ap
university
which is in the southern part of india
well so today i'm going to talk about
gans or the generative adversarial
networks in a faction and then my main
goal
is to actually show you where are
actually guns being used
and then the same problem statement can
we use something else and not that
so yeah so so the topics of the day are
face editing
text generation text image synthesis
using gans as well
and then so i'll be showing you two
images i just want to know whether you
can
tell me whether these are synthetic
generated or are they real
or not so now we have two images which
is a
and b and then i just give you maybe two
seconds time to
decide which is fake or which is
generated
and then which is real so if you're
thinking either one of them
you might be partially correct because
both of them are actually generated by
guns or using
neural networks so i mean i mean one
quick way to find out whether
an image is fake or synthetic is just
find out near
the edges where you have two or more
colors or two or more pixels
joining in so that will show you kind of
smudges if you stick here and here and
i mean i mean that's one way of actually
finding it something synthetic
well so uh so this was the i mean i mean
this is done by
uh indian space interpretation and
there's basically
uh face editing when you have an
original image and then you change it to
uh another entirely different image
right of the same person
so this is being uh done using age
progression but you can apply the same
thing for you know putting up sunglasses
or you know growing up the beard or
removing the beard i mean you can do all
kinds of facial attributes
so so i mean these kind of
what you call modifications or
manipulations can be done by miniguns
and then a few examples
are interface guns cycle guns sea guns
and age grounds
well so i mean we we don't know what our
guns are but do you know what actually
happens behind them i mean i mean guns
have been in the news from the past
maybe one or two years and then we've
seen a lot of defects on
obama and you know many other uh videos
etc
so but what exactly are guns or you know
what's what's happening
inside or behind the scenes of general
uh generative adversarial networks
well so as you know it's it's it it
comes under generator modeling on
generative algorithms and you have two
neural networks there
and so what you have is a generator and
a discriminator so
so the job of generator is to sit and
create the closest realistic images
possible
maybe it can be from random noise or it
could be some
samples given to it and the job of a
discriminator is to sit and identify
whether
the images treated are real or fake so i
mean it's more like a
person who just essentially whether a
particular signature is a forgery or not
so i mean i mean that way you you have a
generator and a discriminator
playing a game and to check whether the
distance that is able to
uh what you call detect fake and real
images
and the generator wants to see that it
generates a fake image that is as good
as a real image
so essentially it's a minimax game
between two neural networks
well so i mean this is a pictorial
representation of a gun or or
guns and the new network so you so as i
was saying you have a random noise or
this random noise
which is being fed to the generator and
then it starts generating a face
and then and then you have some real
field source of sample data that is
again being
taken to the discriminate defined which
is fake and real
well so and then and for the math nerds
i mean for the math guys and the nerds
there
this is an equation i mean this is this
is a very popular equation or this is
the
main equation which uh which is the
essence of what happens
behind gans which is i mean the first
part of the
equation which is the uh log of d of x
and then it's an exponential which is
happening which shows that the log
probability that d
correctly predicts a real data x r here
which is so
so the descriptor id checks whether it
can
predict the data real i mean the data is
real or not which is true positive like
can you can can it actually tell okay
this is a real image and then i'm
determining
i'm detecting it as a real image and the
next part shows that
whether the distance can actually uh
what you call detect whether the
generated data is generated
or not and then it's generated as well
so so that's the
uh uh i mean i mean i mean that's what
happens we are behind the scenes of
grams right so
let's talk about face editing isn't it
so face editing is very much
right now in the market i mean in the in
the industry of course
so we use it for a lot of photoshop i
mean recently photoshop did
i mean a lot of plugins have been
released for photoshop wherein you can
change the image
uh attributes like the facial hair or
the age etc
so let's talk face editing now let's say
i have tom cruise
and i want our agent to look like this
so i mean what are the few
main attributes of a few main features
you would like to
i mean you would want the network to
perform i mean let's say
maybe the wrinkles on the face
the color of the hair maybe the
folds on the forehead maybe the bulging
or the
swelling of the nose i mean these are
you know common attributes which happen
to a person as he or she ages but how do
you teach in your network
this is what you're supposed to do
you're supposed to turn black
or any kind of hair into white because
they've
i mean because they've grown older so
what exactly happens
behind this particular gun or this
particular is interface then what
exactly happens is gone
learns the somatic in the linear
subspaces which is let's say i have each
and every
attribute like the uh like the mustache
the hair
the wrinkles and everything so so so
it's one particular
i mean they're like different uh
attributes put into a one particular
linear subspace
so gans learn where each and every uh
semantics or attributes are in the
substance
and then there's a manipulation
happening to the facial attributes there
depending on that there's a study or
there's a small correlation
happening in semantics i mean different
variants semantic like the facial hair
and etcetera
and then once you're done with that then
you go for uh distilling them or you
just
what you call uh separate them it's like
it's like i separate the mustache from
my face
into an attribute to the oils or to
separate vector so
what essentially gone wants to do is it
wants to take my mistakes and then put
on the target image on the
target uh or the target person i'm
trying to change and then i i mean
that's what happens which is attribute
manipulation for various
facial features although it sounds so
easy and looks so easy but it's
quite a big problem for many of the
researchers now because dance have a lot
of
problems when you're training and then
i'll i'll i'll for sure
also talk about that so i mean so now
we've seen how gans are in action now
let's say i want to do the same thing
which is
uh do age progression but without guns
i mean that that sounds intriguing right
because because gans are known for
this particular what you call magical
stuff but
how i mean can we do it with just simple
neural networks that convents can we do
it
and the answer is yes we can so this is
another
method which has been proposed by quite
a few
scientists in china and and the name is
deep feature interpolation so the other
one we saw was latent space
interpretation
because it's taking the attributes from
the latent space and then trying to
paste it on your source or the target
image you want to
change the features for and this is
interpolation so
essentially as the name suggests it is
interpolating the features from the
comments
so and then this can be implemented
using simple vgg uh
19 neural network and then and then i
know pretty much who be i mean
all of you who who have been in the area
of image recognition and all you know
that vdg 19 is a very popular network
uh used for uh hobby uh training and et
cetera
i mean you train object projects etc
so so what essentially dfi does is it
takes the features of the desired facial
attributes and it maps them
to the target images so that way what
exactly happens is
it's it's pretty much what uh interface
gun is doing
but it's just doing it with the help of
simple neural network without any gun
i mean i mean without any discriminator
and a generator
and then and then the best part is in
few cases this beats the state of the
art like this does beat uh
what you call interface gun this just
beat age gun and all the guns which have
actually been
i mean which have actually proven to be
a very good uh benchmark or
or which have been proven uh proven to
be a benchmark in the
research community so i'll just take you
to the
uh background or what happens for each
step right so let's say
as i was saying you have a target uh
face and then you have a source
phase so now our main goal is to see
that uh
let's have uh piano leaves and i want to
remove this mustache and then
and then how do i do it so i i i have
two
uh source sets i mean i do have two sets
one is a source
one is the target set and then my source
set has
all the images or all the faces without
a mustache
and then the target set has all the
images with room stabs or with facial
end
and then i map them into deep feature
space or there or i map them into
feature space
as as it's shown here and then once
you're mapping it you're simple
i mean you're simply using combinational
layers and then you're telling where
exactly is this particular
person in the future or or you're
teaching the network to to learn the
feature of each and every attribute
after that's done then you can't then
you compute the attribute vector
of both the faces without
facial and with fascia and then once
that is done
you just interpolate them which is you
just change the
uh faces in the uh in the background but
you just let them once that
stay there or it's essentially more like
just pasting the moon stats from one
place to the other
and then once that happens you just
reverse map it again using
uh coordinates and then you have robert
downey jr
without mustache so so i mean i mean
that's one way you can actually do this
and then so so this pretty much proved
that you don't need you don't actually
need gas for these kind of
uh problems also although
although these are very very what you
call these might take a lot of time to
train but
essentially you do you you don't have to
worry about the problems faced by guns
such as
uh diminishing what you call uh
vanishing radiance or
more collapse which are which i'll be
talking about so this is one example of
how dfi can actually be used to
uh age a woman so as you can see
there's a wrinkle there's a change in
the uh ie structure and etc
and and the way her lips have been
darkened and etc so i mean this
so this is one way in which you can use
dfi
and then essentially it is not uh
not an alternative for integra but this
is one way you can
do stuff so yeah but sometimes guns seem
to impress and disappoint at the same
time so
although you're using guns and you know
it's a very good way to generate
what you call systemic data or strategic
images they they do seem to
uh what you call disappoint us sometimes
and then sometimes it happens
the database is specifically not made
for your problems children are made
especially for you because you might be
working on a completely different
problem
but but the kind of data you have
doesn't support your
goal or vision so phage aging generally
yield the kind of output expected
sometimes though it looks and i mean
though
so you have a lot of wrinkles although
the image has a lot of
facial hair it doesn't feel real logical
so so let's say i mean i hope you can
see the video wherein
if you just see my face uh i know i mean
you can you can recognize me at this
particular point in time or
this particular point in instance but
but but once i go a bit younger i i
don't think you logically
can correlate is that my face or not
because because
this this particularly happened because
the
train data used was celib or this
liberty a database
or the data set which had a lot of what
you call american and european actors
than the indianapolis so so the facial
structure changes the way
the person look changes and everything
changes with including the color
so that way uh the gun failed to
actually
i mean failed to create an angular
version of me whereas it did
it did quite seem good when it was going
with the other foreign actors like britt
marley christinans and
paul walker but but again there was a
small problem with
gal gator's face as well and maybe so so
this is one basic problem which grants
face because
uh it's it's again all about your data
the way you're using it
so so again what have you noticed
although the trade uh transformation
looks real relatively logical does it
feel legit or does it feel real like
can you tell okay prana is going to look
like this in future but
is he is he looking like this when he
was young i mean you can correlate right
because
because as you grow your facial
structure changes the same maybe the way
uh your what you call attributes
uh remains the same but the structure
remains the same right
so again maybe again it's maybe in few
cases younger version do seem real
but have you observed the others again
so this is because a small ratio of
indian and foreign faces
uh causes this particular problem in
gods
but again so i mean i mean i mean that's
one particular thing which a lot of
people who work on dance especially in
uh what you call in a generation phase
about
face a lot but the the these are a few
problems which a lot of us face when
you're going with plants which is
generate uh gradient vanishes this is
because your disputed is very much
successful i mean it is so good
that your gender stops learning and it's
like absolutely this
stops so after that most probably
this this i mean this happens to a lot
of people which is the number of samples
genetically very very less there's no
diversity there's no what you call
different samples uh what you call
output coming up so that way
there is no proper diversity in the
samples and this way
the the whole system collapses or it's
called as more collapse
and then the other big problem is
non-convey non-convergence which is more
parameters do not convince the oscillate
but
which is the loss function and the other
one they did not converge is
go parallel so that way this is a very
big problem which a lot of us
face when using dance so i mean now
we've talked about image generation and
image synthesis let's talk about takes
generation
so i mean i mean a lot of us who've been
working on nlp know about the ls teams
and the transformer models isn't it
so now so now what i mean i mean you
pretty much know that depending on the
softmax function you
you predict what is the next word which
is to be uh what you call coming in the
sentence or you you put it based on the
probability which
word is supposed to be uh what you call
inserted next
but the biggest problem here is all of
us know that the next
next word is is uh what i call is
chosen with respect to probability and
this is a non-differentiable
operation but when talking about guns we
essentially back propagate so the law is
determined by the distributor is
supposed to be non
is is supposed to go by a
non-differentiable picking
but the biggest problem again here is
backdrop is depend on differentiability
so so so when you have a
non-differentiable function which is
which is supposed to go
using differentiable operation there's
this clash so so so it doesn't happen
actually
so this was solved by a few scientists
using reinforcement algorithms and
policy gradients
which which sounds really cool again
it's again very very difficult to
implement
see i mean so so right now there's a
paper called c gwan or sequence gone as
you call it and then you have a
generator which produces discrete tokens
of
text i mean as you know you you first
embed the vector and then you convert it
into a uh zero one uh
call i mean a matrix and then and then
you have a descriptor which provides a
reward for every generated sequence
which is like like let's say i have a
word i generate a sequence for it like i
finish up with the sentence and then and
the defender gives me a reward so this
is done using a set of policies or a set
of policy gradients
so this is an example of how it looks uh
in sequence gun which is you have a
generator
with the true data and then and it keeps
on training it
and sends it to the distributor here on
the other side you have g which is a
state and then you have
every state has an action isn't it and
depending on an action
it finishes using something called as
motor car as search so so what monitor
caller search does is let's say i have a
uh prompt called as he is and then and
then it fills with the other blank he is
a good boy
or he is or or he is a superman so so
these are different uh
ways it can fill up the sentence or you
can fill up the sequence so so on
every generated sequence there's a
reward being sent back to the to the
generator with
i mean which is the policy gradient here
so this is a sample output i've done
using uh c
down which is as you can see also also
grammatically it looks correct
but there's no continuation from one
sentence i mean the story does not see
this
what you call stay the same there's a
very much difference in what's happening
here for example
it's it's talking about league of
legends here again it's talking about
a completely different thing on the
other side
it's it's it's talking about guides and
etc so i mean there is one thing which
is
again a problem with gas is this this
very much depends on the kind of you're
training it with and
the kind of policies you are trying to
put up
and then so i mean right now we have
discussed both text
and image synthesis so now let's talk
about text image like
what if i can train a new network which
is giving it some text and then
having it generate an image of that and
then pretty much sure a lot of girls
have seen
the wonderful uh model uh what they call
uh shown by openai which is dolly and
then this was
i mean again this is based on dc grounds
or deep convolutional knots
so again deep conventional generative
adversarial networks is the performance
you know
and then so essentially again this i
mean so everywhere in glance you have a
generator iron
that's the basic rule of dance but again
the way you arrange it and the way you
process data which is going through it
completely changes
so so so coming back to dc grants we
have a generator
and then you have a conversational
transpose layer so so although you have
a
combination it's just exactly reverse or
it's a or it's a converse of it sorry or
it's a transpose of it
and then you have a discriminator which
is a normal convolutional network
or a layer and then so so so this is the
main
uh architecture behind dali which is
built by open ai and then pretty much
most of you who are in the community
must have seen
the kind of results dali gives us so so
it's also called the transformer
language model because it
it has text embedded into each and every
uh sample being
fed through the neural network so so
again this can be used to
regenerate any pc portion from the image
and then yeah so coming to behind the
scenes you have a generator network as
you know i mean this is a simple
generating drug as you see in every
garden
and you have a discriminate network
again which is again as simple as any
other gun
but the catch here is you you you embed
a particular text with the image itself
so as you can see
it says this flower has a small round
violet petals with dark purple synthetic
so again that's being encoded
into a vector and then it's being fed to
the
general network as a simple feature so
that way
the network learns along with the text
that this particular text corresponds to
this particular image
and the same is being done when when in
the in the description
in the descriptor again it's it's trying
to predict whether this particular
uh image corresponds to this particular
text or not so text encoding is
performed and used by both
generator and distributed what
essentially happens is that the same
text encoding happens when it processes
uh the particular text into a lower
dimension and then features
and then and then feature maps to the
image
image of the comment so so i mean see
this is this is a very very small
uh process but the way you implement is
very very difficult
and then so this is an example output of
what dali generates you can you can
access it from going to openai's website
and then it's quite i mean you can do a
lot of uh combinations and then get
crazy outputs
so this is an example output which is a
photo of a magazine cover from the
and then the and then you have various
ears so this was done so you you have a
text from given and it's giving you a
uh generated out of it so i mean this
was done entirely using dc guards
you can you can read the paper as well
it's it's publicly available in
archives and then i'll show you another
example so this is a photo for from from
various various years or maybe from the
90s 50s 60s 70s and 80s
so this was entirely generally using uh
dali and then
it's and then so the the the other good
thing about dali is it
it pretty much has its background go
through the concept of flip clip which
is
another
model uh released by open air which
predicts which which tries to predict
is a particular image corresponding to
the kind of problem you have on it so so
it's a reverse
i mean it's the other way around but
still this is the this is the
whole concept of guards of action and
then before i end
uh just wanted to mention a couple of
points which is
uh guns have been one of the major part
to generate deep fakes and then the figs
are in the entire news and are in the
entire
what you call radar under the concept of
ethics so in case you want to
uh what you call explore
guns and want to generate some deep fix
i'm pretty much sure just use it for
academic
purposes and not for any other so thanks
a lot everyone
uh thanks you can you can ping me at
p compelli on twitter or you can meet me
at the completed gmail.com thanks a lot
yeah i guess that's it from my side
thank you yeah
do we have any questions
do we
first one is the
most challenging one um
i think i had a question okay
um when you show yourself in this
um imaging like in this time
lapse thing did you
look anything like that when you were a
kid no
not at all i guess i just wanted to show
a picture of mine when i was young but
yeah this one right
so i i don't i mean i i compare and
check but
nowhere am i like actually looking like
that i mean
that that that's a very uh what you call
uh interesting two things to search up
on because again although guns can do
wonders it's again
i mean it's coming back to the
fundamentals that it is not correct
so yeah but
actually did they check real picture
because
even if it looked realistic maybe the
people were not looking like that
yeah i mean yeah uh i didn't have i mean
i could just find a photo of christine
and son and try to check
maybe at some point in the time lapse he
he
he might be looking you know i mean
comparatively at least close yeah
there was this uh what you call
resemblance but it's it's
it's it's only for the uh what you call
the indians or the other
very very less ratio of people in the
data set
which there's a problem for
but apart from that yeah i mean there's
a close resemblance for the others if
you just check
maybe
great yeah
so um i have a question
on this x2 image thing is it an open
source implementation the
the dc car yeah i mean
right now i mean uh opena did not
release it for
uh what i call general purposes the way
you did for gpt2
but i've seen i've seen quite a few uh
what you call reverse engineering codes
or i mean people have tried their best
to use
dc guns to build these kind of stuff but
but open ai they haven't done it
open since as of now okay
thanks
and did they plan to or they plan to try
to
sell it or commercialize it
yeah i mean the biggest problem these
guys have is
they are still taking an ethical aspect
of it i mean even before the release gpt
road there was a very big
uh what they called uh what do you call
this this there was this big
vibe of ethical aspect coming and i mean
an ethical trilemma of whether to
release this model
and then can it go into wrong hands if
it goes into wrong hands what happens
so i mean with the same motor i'm pretty
much sure these guys are still
you know put i mean a bit uh calm and
composed when releasing the gpt3 as well
so i mean they haven't done it public
yet but yeah few people did get it on
what you call a few vertical priority
basis on the on the kind of work they
did
but yeah maybe maybe maybe in another
couple of months we might
see open air releasing it as a as an api
or maybe an open model for testing maybe
a 561m model or something like that
thanks yeah
okay so if no one has more
question then i will say thank you
pranav again for the
great presentation thanks for having me
here
and i will stop the recording
and the youtube live so